zoosk first testifier for european  council president donald tusk addressing  mep simply nuri he defended the  conclusions of december's on it central  on the agenda yonkers 315 billion euro  investment plan to relaunch growth now  it is for you as legislators along with  the council to ensure that the font is  ready by June a considerable slice of  these funds is to be raised by  attracting private capital one criticism  of the Commission president's plan is  that Richard EU countries may benefit  most but some MEP is are now more  reassured Younker plan will help banks  in Greece to lend to small and medium  enterprises by guaranteeing and  potential losses criticisms also  surround poverty reduction in Europe Oh  Chaudhary are no hope I a circus over  travajas queda Parvati diffusion sociali  lat sue Johnny he a new da the  conclusion we can say another issue  raised with Ukraine under certain  conditions the country is set to receive  a new political and financial aid